if you don't mind in your world what is
to the average person that doesn't know
what Lupron is what is Lupron yeah
Lupron was used to chemically castrate
uh pedophiles and now there's a small
dose in it in puberty blockers yep and
so over time this is this is the
scariest part with this narrative is
people say puberty blockers does nothing
um I would argue that if you put a child
on puberty blockers at 11 and then they
stop at 19 20. it's not just going to
resume puberty it's not a puberty
delayer you know it's a puberty blocker
so these things are are changing the
chemicals of your body and castrating
you over time yeah here's the article it
says thousands of deaths linked to drugs
used as puberty blockers for gender
confused kids if you can go a little
lower uh this is an article from 2019.
it got some criticism I'll give the
backside of this as well so September
20th of 2019 UK National Health Services
NHS is investigating drugs that are used
to block normal sexual development among
children and teens who are transitioning
to to the opposite sex that when used in
other applications have been linked to
6000 that's the drug is question in
question are used to lower the levels of
testosterone and estrogen which are
built in blocks of sexual development
and sexual function the use of these
drugs in other areas of medicine to
combat prostate cancer for instance has
been associated with serial mental
conditions including cases of nervous
systems psychiatric disorders heart
failure seizures joint pain bone
deterioration and dozens of other
adverse uh events the FDA listed over 41
000 adverse reactions between 2004 and
2019 associated with luprolite which
includes Lupron and similar drugs used
by General clinics almost 26 000 of
these were classified as serious cases
which also includes six thousand that's
and I'll read this next part is FDA
indicates that amongst three to 17 year
olds who had taken the drug for various
medical conditions they were reported
almost 1500 sections over 700 being
serious and 11 of those resulting in
death of the cases resulting in that the
drug was used to delay puberty treat
growth disorder or drug therapy as in
hormone suppression therapy among other
things Tom
yeah so this is this this drug is a drug
that was developed to and if you look up
there's a condition that affects young
girls called precocious puberty it's
when the pituitary gland
um is out of sync with the biological
Age and what the Lupron does and it's
given in the thigh like once a quarter
with careful monitoring of hormone
levels and specifically bone density
because at puberty you notice that the
joint pain and everything people are
going to have chronic almost arthritic
joint pain because the bone development
didn't happen so not only is the bone
density but the bone size growth plates
are are completely out of sync and so
you're not just causing a sex change
what you are doing is you are chemically
changing the entire structure of that
person's body and they don't come out
the same on the other side in the case
of precocious puberty you do it once a
quarter they monitor it carefully pure
you think of like defibrillating a heart
that's beating him properly well it kind
of defibrillates the and I know doctors
probably listening to get on the chat
and say it's a wrong way to look at it
but it does it sort of resets the
pituitary gland to say hey calm down
this is what we need you to do and then
it was used in adults adult males when
you give them that it'd be it's the
chemical castration for serial
pedophiles that we don't know what to do
with them so we're gonna give them this
big time toxic drug and we're gonna
throw them in prison and so that's where
big Pharma is like anything and by the
way this was eight grand a shot that is
the market price for Lupron was eight
grand a shot so parents that had this
that was a twenty four thousand dollar a
year Neutron minus eight grand a shot go
see if you can find uh I saw the
revenues a 752 million dollars in 2020
based on just this drug yeah I'm sure he
could go to like drugs.com you know the
online
um uh online legal pharmacies you know
you could go you type in Lupron price of
Lupron per shot
price of Lupron per shot you'll see
prices showing with and without uh
health insurance by the way
there you go 1729 that may be monthly
multiply that times three and there's
your there's your once again it's got it
got it well 1700 times three that's
forty five fifty two hundred dollars got
it so so so to me when you're looking at
when you're looking at this okay so then
this leads me to the next conversation
why why such a big push for let the kids
take it if they want to before 18 years
old okay let them do it what's wrong
with that you should let them do it if
they want to do it on the parent
supports it let them go through the
process of taking this before 18 years
old why is there such a big push for
that
um I would argue that it's it's the
income you know big Pharma looks at this
as a cash cow and and if you listen to a
lot of D transitioners they are not
supported
um you know down the journey a lot of
them you know were guided especially
like someone like Chloe Cole was guided
down a journey to to go in transition
but yet didn't fully understand what she
was getting herself into didn't really
have the mental capacity at 16 15 to say
you know what I'm gonna have a double
mastectomy because I really want to be a
boy and so when you pair that with big
pharma's dirty greed you have all of
these children now that are suffering
medical consequences because they're
using data from children that are
suffering from medical illness that need
these drugs but now they're trying to
give it to healthy normal functioning
children and now we have all of these
things happening to them so when you
look at Pharma it's it's hard for people
to understand this is a new drug not
everybody's going to be familiar with
this it's the same game over and over
again so you have to look at it in terms
of something that's that's very
relatable for example birth control
pills big Pharma encourages doctors and
suppliers to consistently give out birth
control pills to young women at a very
young age you have young some young
women walking into doctor's offices for
acne for the regular cycle they're not
asked about their diet you don't look at
their stress level you don't look at any
other components that could be causing
that and they hand these birth control
pills over to young kids who then young
girls sometimes are taking these pills
from the age of 13 years old straight
through 25 years old you're now seeing a
ton of studies by the way that show that
these women have bone density issues at
a very young age they're going in for
scans at the age of 40 and they're
having bone density issues because at an
age when they were supposed to be at
their maximum capacity to build bone
they were impeded from doing that
because they were taking birth control
pills so you see the farmer recipe is oh
let's just disseminate drugs not
investigate you know what could actually
be going on lifestyle wise and otherwise
to fix this problem so now you bring in
these other drugs it's the same thing
you create a drug dependent person women
on when you talk about birth control are
very hesitant to get off because then
they're dependent they don't want to
mess up their bodies they're like oh I'm
in this routine there's a lot of panic
that goes into what are the side effects
of coming off you're going to have the
same thing with this drug whether it's
Lupron or whatever is coming down the
pike next from Pharma they want people
consistently dependent on these drugs
afraid to get off of them and it's a
permanent I think you've said it Tom
it's a cash cow it's a lifetime Cash Cow
in a lot of cases and then people who do
de-transition and go off of them will
talk to you about it's not so easy to do
that as as any person who's taken any
drug any Pharma drug will tell you you
could take something as simple as a a
proton pump inhibitor for your stomach
for acid reflux there's a weaning
process that goes into that this is not
easy stuff Pharma knows it and the more
people they have Reliant and dependent
on these drugs from a young age the more
money they make it's very simple and by
the way I'll be big Pharma right well my
spreadsheet says that if you're on birth
control pills right up to the point of
uh premenopausal you know what that just
means I get you on the osteoporosis
medication earlier right and now that's
right but wait wait your joints hurt you
have issues no problem I have a cocktail
of osteoporosis medications I got stuff
for your hot flashes I've got stuff to
deal with the pain in your joints and
then and and because if you if you take
a look at it you could look at each
human being as a lifetime customer of
Pharma you can you can look at it
exactly along you know those lines you
know I I think I didn't bring up media
when I had my you know angry summary 10
minutes ago because you worked in media
and you saw pharma's influence on on
media because of the amount of spend
that they have and and we are what's the
other country besides us that's allowed
to New Zealand New Zealand's there's 22
countries out there that allowed to
advertise like this and and you you
lived in this so I I didn't bring up
media because I I've studied Pharma and
I've studied a lot of other things but I
haven't lived in and studied me so let's
let's go let's go with the with this uh
uh next thing about puberty blockers and
what it does so question becomes the
following so alcohol what what age is
legal age to drink alcohol
21 okay what age do I need to be to
smoke cigarettes 21 in California okay
how about if I want to uh buy a gun
I think 18 yeah 18 18. okay uh what if
uh oh what if my dad if I'm let's just
say I'm 13 years old okay and I go to a
bar and my dad says okay give him a shot
of tequila can we do that no but my dad
said it's okay
right in 50 states your dad but wait a
minute you're right if I go if my dad
knows what's best for me and I go to a
bar
and I say Dad I want to do a double shot
of tequila because it's been a long
freaking day in school bro it's been
tough honestly I need a double shot of
tequila right and my dad looks at the
bartender Mary it's okay give him a
double shot of tequila but he's only 13.
I'm over 21 I'm 34. it's okay go ahead
and give it to him Mary's gonna say hey
buddy I'm not gonna lose my license do
you realize how stupid that sounds like
what I just said right now how stupid it
sounds now here's the argument Dwyane
Wade is a hero
he's a hero he wants to allow his uh
younger kid to transition and if the
father approves you should let him do
that that's a good father in today's age
in today's age the international women's
day Joe Biden recognizes a trans male
who is now a woman as the woman of the
year do you realize the level of
hypocrisy in these arguments so if a 35
year old father cannot go to a bar with
his 13 year old son and have a double
shot of tequila because he's given the
permission what makes you give that
argument to say how is this argument
creating momentum I guess is what the
question is how
yeah so a lot of the studies that that
justify you know gender affirming care
for children are done through surveying
these children that were indoctrinated
so you'll get a child you know starting
you know puberty and in two years
they'll ask that indoctrinated child if
if you feel like you're going to commit
suicide if you feel better and if you
tell that child for years and years and
years that you're a boy in a girl's body
and now they're starting to become a
girl you just manipulated that child
into being okay with what is happening
with them and so that's why this this
journey of just affirming is highly
highly dangerous because you're not
giving the child the opportunity to grow
up and make that that devastating or or
hard decision for their life at an age
where where they cannot fully understand
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
thank you